(logo clicking)
- We all wish we had a dope car.
Right, Teddy?
So today, I'm gonna show
you how to get one for free.
(beatboxing) Free car!
- [Teddy] I would not cheat
on you with no albino!
- First, find a car
that no one needs.
If a guy has a car this
nice, he has other ones.
He doesn't need em all.
- [Teddy] So, you don't think
he's gonna notice
a missing Cadillac?
- No.
The cool thing about locksmiths
is they don't check to
make sure it's your car
before they unlock it for you.
- [Locksmith] Wait, what?
- [Teddy] Oh, no, you good, bro,
just keep doin' your thing.
- Bro, we're in.
- [Teddy] Dog, we don't
even have the keys.
- Why would we need the keys?
Oh, yeah, to...
Okay.
- Why I gotta think for you.
- [Video] Hotwire a car,
okay?
- Okay.
- [Video] So take your red wire.
- [Teddy] Find a red wire, dog.
- There's no wires.
How I'm gonna hotwire this
- Dog, just stop...
- with no wires?
- Oh snap, he's coming,
he's coming!
Get in the back.
- Shut the doors.
- [Teddy] Get in the back.
- So, at this part,
be really quiet.
Don't make any noise.
- Shh!
Shut your punk ass up.
- Shut up.
- You got me in this trunk.
He's closin' the door.
Why are we in the trunk?
- Okay, shh, shut up.
- [Teddy] Why are you lying
down in my man position?
Why you got an arm...
- I don't know where we are.
- [Teddy] Why he got books?
- Stop askin' questions.
- Back here in the garage.
Like I always say, before
you earn, you gotta learn.
It's not enough
to just want to...
What the hell?
Who are you?
- [Teddy] Ain't you
the dude from YouTube?
- And if you join my program,
you can be making
60 grand a month
like these two right here.
- Ha, so how do
we get this again?
- Shut up, bro, don't
ask any questions.
- Don't ask.
- Food is way too expensive.
Right, Teddy?
- Right.
- So we're gonna
show you how to get
free food from delivery.
(beatboxing)
Free food!
- [Teddy] That song trash.
- [Man] Bro, tape me.
- [Teddy] I like nature, my bad.
- We gotta go to a place where
there's a lot of rich kids
and they're too lazy
to walk three blocks.
- [Teddy] We came
to fraternity, what?
I thought we was
going to Brentwood.
- No.
- I'm tryin' to see
OJ's house.
- Blend into your surroundings.
I got the snapback,
the headphones,
the cutoff tee, the
basketball shorts,
the socks, the slides...
- And don't forget
the classic red cup, breh.
- True.
Now you just gotta wait
for the delivery guy.
- [Teddy] Horseshoe E K, what?
Ricky Ricardo out
here delivering...
- Are you Josh?
- Yeah.
- [Teddy] And he
just gave it to him,
he didn't even ask
for no ID or nothin'.
- And that's how you
get free delivery food.
It's that easy.
- Oh, that's what's up.
Hey who's... is
that your friend?
- [Frat Boy] Is that my food?
- What?
- [Frat Boy] Come on!
- Teddy!
Teddy!
- [Teddy] I found security, bro.
You finna get beat up.
- And that's
how you get
- Better give him
the food, man.
free delivery food.
- Nobody takes my roast beef.
(shouting, camera cutting out)
- Coffee is way too expensive.
Right, Teddy?
- Dog, my tiddy meat's
sweatin', can you hurry up?
- Okay, so we're gonna show
you how to get free coffee.
(beatboxing)
Free coffee.
- [Teddy] And yo songs be trash.
Why you out here lookin'
like a do-rag model?
- I gotta look intimidating.
That's why I got the
do-rag, the chain,
the tall tee, the timbs, tears.
- [Teddy] You don't
know what those mean.
- Lil Wayne has em.
Just wait until they call
out something you want
and then take it.
No one will stop you,
cause everyone at the
coffee shop is a bitch.
- Almond no-whip
mocha for Shannon.
- And it's that easy.
- [Teddy] Wow.
- And that's how
you get free c...
- Excuse me, bro.
I think you took my coffee.
- Oh, I'm so sorry.
(Teddy laughing)
I didn't know it was...
- What's up, homie?
How you get punked by
a dude named Shannon?
(laughing)
- Usually, that works, but
it didn't work this time,
cause I actually don't
like almond milk,
so I let him...
- But you like tiddy milk,
cause you're a little baby.
- You the one with tiddies.
- [Teddy] Oh, you body-shamin'?